hi there steve here i'm gonna jump in
and do a video two days in a row here
because i had a comment
on uh my last video someone said uh you
know uh i'm gonna correct your english
uh it's not better or i think younger i
referred to a friend that i met who was
five years younger than me and she said
no no it's younger than i
very interesting
uh on several levels first of all
i'm not a fan of correcting people when
they speak whether they're speaking
their native language or some other
language i'm against it in fact
i say even in terms of when you're when
i'm speaking with my tutor in russian or
ukrainian
i want them to send me a list afterwards
in google documents or on a reported
link of the mistakes that i made but i
don't want to be interrupted because
actually i'm trying to communicate i'm
communicating meaning and i don't want
people to be analyzing my grammar while
i'm communicating meaning that's just my
and i don't do it to other people
i try not to at any rate but second of
all
this whole point about
uh younger than me bigger than me versus
i
uh
i you know grammar
is
based on two things in a sense it's
based on
practice how do people use usage how do
people use the language
and to some extent it's based on logic
uh in terms of usage there's no question
that far more people say
bigger than me or older than me
or
same as me
than say bigger than i if i hear someone
say bigger than i it sounds strange so
overwhelmingly usage
favors than me
and the logic of that is that the word
than can either be a conjunction
or a preposition if it's a conjunction
then it sort of
uh
connects two equal phrases clauses so
bigger than i am i mean no one would say
bigger than me
bigger than i am younger than i am
but when it's
then is also identified in the
dictionary as a preposition so when it's
used as a preposition bigger than me
uh
more than ever
uh there it's used as a preposition so
i guess it's not incorrect to assume as
some people say that bigger than me is
actually bigger than i
is sort of uh
you know we've taken the am out of it so
it really means bigger than i am but
there is no am there so bigger than i is
also okay
i would never criticize anyone for
saying bigger than i it just sounds a
bit strange to me
further in the sense of logic it's
interesting and of course i wanna i'm
taking this beside my french cafe here
it's interesting when you speak a number
of different languages
that you can look at how certain things
are treated in other languages the
interesting thing is that
french and and i consider french to have
had a great influence on english simply
because there's i mean half of the 60 of
the vocabulary in english comes from
norman french so french had a major
influence on english in french they say
please come one
they don't say please
they might say plus joe and there they
might even add in prison
or whatever plus you lose me because
there's this
call it the expletive the the redundant
nu in french but leaving that out of it
it's
so they use
the uh the
objective for moi but in spanish they
don't ma
uh in german
so uh and i can't go through
[Music]
like all the other languages seem to
agree with the concept that
that the more than the comparative
comparing equals uh if it's a s
you know nominative or subject here it's
a subject there but french doesn't do it
that way and overwhelmingly english
doesn't do it that way so
um i think it's an interesting subject
it comes up all the time
i'm sticking to the way i normally use
the language and the way i hear the
majority of people use the language and
even in writing i will say more than me
i won't say i won't write more than i
unless i'm saying writing more than i am
so i think that's kind of an interesting
uh bit of a controversy there i'm sure
there are people who disagree with me
and so uh you know i look forward to
hearing your views on this
it has like to do with korean in fact i
haven't done any korean yet i better get
out of it bye for now